-Welcome. Enjoy yourselves.
Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you for watching at home.
Man, it was an exciting weekend
in -- in sports.
The Kentucky Derby.
Did you see this?
It's the second biggest upset
in the race's 148-year history.
It won --
80-1 was the long shot.
Yeah. And it was named --
Rich Strike
was the name of the horse.
Rich Strike, which sounds more
like your local anchor
who does sports and weather.
[ Laughter ]
"And now with Rich Strike
with the weather."
[ Light laughter ]
Rich Strike sounds like
a pack of cigarettes
your grandma used to smoke.
[ Laughter ]
"Give me a pack
of Rich Strikes."
[ Light laughter ]
The horse's odds were 80-1.
Yeah, that's like if today
I was talking
about President Bill de Blasio.
You know what I'm saying?
Can you -- do you understand
what that means?
Meanwhile, this weekend was also
Mother's Day, of course.
Happy Mother's Day
to all the mothers out there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I saw that First Lady
Jill Biden
spent the day in Ukraine and met
with the Ukrainian First Lady.
Yeah. Basically, Joe got her
an edible arrangement
for Mother's Day and
Jill was like, "You know what?
I'm going to go to Ukraine.
I'm good."
And this was actually very cool.
At the request of
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy,
Bono and the Edge held
a surprise concert yesterday
at a subway station in Kyiv.
[ Audience oohs ]
That's amazing. That's --
it was the first time a guy
broke out a guitar
in a subway station
and people actually cheered.
[ Laughter ]
Let's switch gears.
As part of the investigation
against him,
Former President Trump has been
asked to turn over
four cell phones,
but he claims he can't
because he lost all of them.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Trump said he doesn't know
where the phones are.
Then a minute later,
Eric Trump's stomach
started ringing.
[ Laughter ]
[As Trump] "You --
you swallowed --"
[Normally] Well, get this.
A Sherpa in Nepal
has set a new world record
after scaling Mount Everest
for the 26th time.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, so if you think
your friend who just ran
a half marathon is insufferable,
try having lunch with this guy.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, the guy has his reasons.
When asked what motivates him,
he said,
"I have AT&T. It's the only
place I get service.
I got to --"
[ Laughter ]
Well, this isn't good --
A former sheriff's deputy
in Arizona has been arrested
for allegedly crashing weddings
and stealing thousands of
dollars' worth of wedding gifts.
[ Light laughter ]
His friends got suspicious
when they saw
his kitchen had 11 air fryers.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I read that a 1,000-pound
great white shark
has been spotted near
the Jersey shore.
[ Audience oohs ]
Yeah, scientists tagged it with
a tracker a few years ago,
whereas the other sharks off
the coast of Jersey put it,
"He's wearing a wire.
He's wearing --"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, before we go on,
I'd like to take a moment
to thank some of our sponsors
for the "Tonight Show."
because they don't always fit in
the commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
we mention all of them.
So it's time for
the "Tonight Show" sponsors.
Here we go.
-♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
♪ "Tonight Show" sponsors ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
You knew. I wouldn't.
And finally...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That is all for
"Tonight Show" sponsors.